[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le rat de Rungis qui me répond là avec
son pull XXL
les costumes
parce que j'ai une plainte de la
personne il faudrait payer les costumes
quand on est sur des vis à beaucoup de
temps voilà beaucoup de talon quand même
hyper sympa
mais sans piscine
non je dis plus rien
il croit que c'est il est chaud
qui en avait une autre qui arrive non
qu'est-ce que tu dis toi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'avais une envie pressante avant de
faire la chronique et les toilettes les
plus proches c'était dans votre loge je
suis rentré
je sais pas si vous le montrer
je suis rentré dans vos chiottes j'ai vu
ça
c'est quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
tout le monde le reconnaît mais vous
savez que de temps en temps je compare
un peu ce qui se fait dans TPMP et
ailleurs dans le PAF et on a regardé les
lancements des émissions donc quand vous
arrivez si ça sept et tout j'ai regardé
ce qui se faisait dans le monde il y a
que sur C8 qu'il y a des lancements
comme ça c'est apprendre dans les écoles
de journaliste tu as fait un truc là
c'est normal
c'est une pelade c'est une pelade frère
tu as un trou frère c'est pas la
connaître
[Rires]
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et tous heureuse de
vous retrouver dans 28 minutes merci de
votre fidélité
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous ce soir nous souhaitons
aborder une question difficile
importante peut-être un peu tabou y
a-t-il un malaise chez les prêtres
diocésains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde les nouveaux pauvres en France
et dans le monde
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue au chasseur
français Le Mag nous accueillons le
président de la Fédération Nationale des
Chasseurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
bonsoir à tous c'est tambour battante
tambour battant consacré à penser les
images et notre premier invité et
Philippe Descola
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci d'être avec nous ce
soir pour la barre miss va de Raymond
Habib
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
qu'en penses-tu Philibert
sans déconner j'adore
c'est tout ce qui s'est passé pendant
les pubs on va dire tu es génial je te
jure
[Applaudissements]
un compliment mais c'est énorme
tu as tout
gâchés vous le savez et malgré les
années passent tout cela autour de moi y
compris celui qui est à côté de moi non
rien non rien compris pendant les pubs
les micros sont ouverts et une longue
toujours pas compris
on commence avec Mathieu Delormeau qui a
eu un petit crush cette semaine alors ça
c'est vu à l'antenne mais encore plus en
off merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
beaucoup bravo merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
on continue avec encore une fois l'immo
charisme
[Rires]
[Musique]
de Benjamin comme d'habitude merci et
attention c'est très rapide voici la
définition de l'amitié selon Baba
[Musique]
visiblement Baba n'aime pas que le
paddle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on continue avec un échange sympathique
et bienveillant entre Mathieu et Cyril
qui avait visiblement quelque chose de
très important
[Musique]
on tire la chasse d'eau
et à la fin normalement on se lave les
mains pour tout ce qui est question
hygiène tout ça tout ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi parce que je ne touche rien
dans les toilettes donc déjà j'ai pris
un papier toilette pour appuyer sur la
chasse d'eau je suis un psychopathe et
après je ne vais pas ouvrir le robinet
donc je suis allé dans un autre truc
pour aller me laver les mains et j'ai
pris du gel après parce que je ne veux
toucher à rien dans les toilettes je
suis un petit copain mais même toi
d'ailleurs tu me dégoûtes excusez-moi
moi je me suis lavé les mains ouais mais
oui mais ouais mais là-bas je t'explique
ça sert à rien parce que tu touches
moi je suis là ma meuf elle est malade
il est l'heure du retour de l'échelle
des tabacs alors pour ceux qui n'étaient
pas là la semaine dernière ce nouvel
séquence où on monte plus on monte dans
l'échelle plus on a affaire à des gros
bâtards et il y en a un qu'on retrouve à
tout les étages
[Rires]
à tous les étages
première séquence matthieu a trouvé son
petit padawan son nouvel allié c'est
notre stagiaire Zakaria regardez ça ils
ont défoncé c'est très bon chéri
j'ai plein de noms possibles
par exemple
mais d'autres aussi
papa
alors une émission tu as parlé plus que
j'entends sur la semaine
[Applaudissements]
bienveillance répondrait à tous mes
radios ce soir dans un live insta
[Rires]
avec la deuxième niveau de l'échelle des
Tarba avec Mathieu Kelly et Benjamin il
y en a un qui s'est pris des balles
perdues cette semaine le pauvre c'est
alors qu'il est super cool en plus c'est
notre chauffeur gueuler dragueur de
salle mon frérot Lionel Lionel Tim on
adore
[Applaudissements]
déjà
ce qui va arriver
on connaissez le Triangle des Bermudes
découvrez le triangle des connards
[Applaudissements]
et tu fais un travail magnifique ne
t'occupe pas des autres je vais te dire
moi je suis avec toi et de nombreux
chroniqueurs aussi voilà il y a que
notre vin ne te cache ne t'occupe pas de
Mathieu Delorme c'est bon frère on a vu
ça
Lionel tu es formidable mon bébé
t'inquiète pas
et enfin on a défoncé qui on termine
avec la crème Elite de la bataille sur
la plus duo de l'Ormeau
[Rires]
alors amis Gilles Verdez
[Musique]
c'est les gens comme ça
toute sa vie est un et une horreur
chacune de ces idées connes
[Musique]
mais je te dis que je t'aime énormément
je t'aime mais je suis d'accord avec toi
sur pratiquement rien supportable merci
beaucoup merci
[Applaudissements]